قال انا مبعوث الصيني الخاص لشبه الجزيره
الكوريه اليو تشاو ميغان التدريبات
المشتركه المتتاليه لكوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده واليابان وحامله
الطائرات الامريكيه التي تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه قباله شبه جزيره الكوريه هي السبب
الرئيسي في استمرار التوتر في شبه الجزيره
وشدد المبعوث الصيني على ان بلاده تؤيد
دائما السلام والاستقرار في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
حثة الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده
على الالتزام بمبدا صين واحده وعدم السماح
لرئيسه تايوان
بزياره الولايات المتحده وكانت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه قد قالت ان رئيس مجلس نواب
كيف
سيلتقي غدا رئيسه تايوان في كاليفورنيا
التي تصل الى الولايات المتحده بعد جوله
في عدد من دول امريكا الوسطى